one of the most exciting things about
Dragon Ball daa is its production
schedule and okay I know that sounds
freaking boring but the thing is this
thing is built almost like a movie
rather than an anime so let me give you
some juicy context here Dragon Ball Di
has been in the animation stage of its
production for a year at this point an
entire calendar year and the dang show
isn't even set to release until fall
2024 so that will end up being around 2
years worth of Animation most anime are
lucky if they get even a year of
complete production time for Preparation
all the way to air date as in from
scripting through to air date DA has 2
years on animation alone and let's not
even talk about super because super had
only like I want to say 2 months like
not even nearly enough time like da is
the opposite of rushed it has the
ingredients to be one of the most
polished well-rounded visual works of
anime you'll ever see now we just have
to wait and see how it turns out